me
fiber-to-the-home Wow where should we
start
confused about telecom technologies and
acronyms ADSL VDSL xDSL copper cable
fiber broadband high speed bandwidth f
TT CF t TB ftth next-generation access
stop actually it's all very simple
really
all you care about is getting fast
internet to send and receive songs
pictures or videos in an instant making
cheap phone and video calls with family
and friends wherever they are working
from home as easily as in the office
watching HD TV programs or catch-up TV
watching videos on demand playing online
games with friends getting an instant
online backup of data and sharing it
with family and friends and so on it's a
fact that out of all the technologies
and solutions fiber-to-the-home FTTH is
the fastest and most reliable way to
access the Internet what about other
solutions then mobile connections are
much slower than FTTH especially when
several users are in the same area and
sharing the available Network satellite
connections are also much slower than
FTTH they entail a delay which hampers
phone conversations and other
interactive activities other fixed
technologies like ADSL use metal wires
which are about 100 times slower than
fiber to connect your home to the fiber
city network in the mean time
it can take an hour to download an HD
video and that's if you're lucky and no
other family member is using the
Internet at the same time and I heard
your kids complain about this
with fiber-to-the-home you get ultra
fast optical fiber right into your home
office or building how come well because
optical fibers are flexible hair thin
strands of glass which transmit light
ever heard of the speed of light that's
exactly what we mean just imagine with
fiber to the home you would get the film
in minutes even if your kids are on a
video call with their grandmother and
this is not going to end soon
because ftth is completely future proof
and the capacity is virtually unlimited
several million European homes are
already enjoying fibre to the home when
are you getting connected
[Music]